gmos are one of the most controversial
areas of science
genetic engineering is used in many
fields but even though medical
applications like
gm insulin are widely accepted the
debate heats up when it comes to food
and
agriculture why is that why is the same
thing treated so differently
let's try to get to the bottom of this
and explore the facts
the fears and the future of gmos
[Music]
humans have been genetically modifying
plants and animals for thousands of
years
maybe a few of your crops had very good
yields maybe one of your wolves
was especially loyal so you did the
smart thing
and bred the plants and animals that had
traits beneficial to you
traits are just an expression of genes
so with each generation those genes got
more pronounced
after thousands of years almost every
single plant and animal around us
is vastly different from its
pre-domesticated state
if humans have been changing genes for
millennia what makes a so-called
genetically modified organism or gmo
different
selective breeding is basically hoping
for lucky hits
genetic engineering eliminates this
factor we can choose the traits we want
make fruit grow bigger immune to pests
and so on
so why are people concerned about them
let's start with one of the most common
objections to gmos
gene flow meaning gm crops could mix
with traditional crops
and introduce unwanted new
characteristics into them
there is a method that might guarantee
complete prevention but is a big
anti-gmo argument by itself terminator
seeds
the idea is that they could produce
sterile plants requiring farmers to buy
new seeds every year
the very concept of this however caused
a public outcry
stopping the technology being put to use
this brings us back to the unintentional
spreading of engineered dna
there have been cases of gmos growing
where they weren't planted
and traces of modified genes found in
foreign crops
but gm plants can't run wild entirely
many crops pollinate themselves and all
crops have to be related to mingle
there are also cultural methods like
buffer zones to keep unintentional
crossing at a minimum
but if it's possible in principle that a
gmo could unintentionally cross with a
non-gmo
there's actually a more important
question is food that comes from gm
crops
different to food from non-gm crops
this question has been a major concern
from the very beginning
gm plants that are destined to be eaten
are checked for possible dangers
and the results are evaluated by
multiple agencies
after more than 30 years and thousands
of studies the science is in
eating gmo plants is no more risky than
their non-gmo equivalent
but don't just take our word for it
sources for this and other claims are in
the video description
but what about plants that have been
engineered to be toxic
for example bt crops a gene borrowed
from the bacterium bacillus
thuringiensis lets engineered plants
produce a protein
that destroys the digestive system of
specific insect pests
the plant makes its own pesticide
insects that eat it
die that sounds alarming
pesticide sprays can be washed off while
the poison in bt crops is inside the
plant but actually it's not a big deal
poison is really just a question of
different perspectives
what's harmless to one species might
kill another
coffee for example is a poison that
kills insects but is harmless to us
or take chocolate it's dangerous for
dogs but a pleasure for humans
bt crops produce a protein that is
tailored to the specific design of the
digestive tract of certain insects
it's completely harmless for us there's
also the opposite approach
plants that are engineered to be
resistant to certain weed killers
this way farmers can use them widely
killing the other plants competing for
resources without harming the crop
here we get to the dark underbelly of
gmos
for the pesticide industry they are big
business
over ninety percent of all cash crops in
the us are herbicide resistant
mostly two glyphosate as a result the
use of glyphosate has increased greatly
that isn't only bad glyphosate is much
less harmful to humans than many other
herbicides
still this means farmers have a strong
incentive to rely on this one method
only
casting more balanced ways of managing
weeds aside
that's one of the most fundamental
problems with the gmo debate
much of the criticism of this technology
is actually criticism of modern
agriculture
and the business practice of the huge
corporations that control our food
supply
this criticism is not only valid it's
also important
we need to change agriculture to a more
sustainable model
gmos as a technology are actually an
ally and not an enemy in that fight
helping to save and protect nature and
minimize our impact on the environment
[Music]
let's look at some positive examples
eggplant is an important crop in
bangladesh but often whole harvests are
destroyed by pests
farmers had to rely heavily on
pesticides not only was this very
expensive
farmers also frequently got sick the
introduction of a new gm eggplant in
2013 stopped this
the same bt protein we talked about
before an effective killer of insects
but harmless to humans
was engineered into them this reduced
insecticide use on eggplants by more
than 80 percent
the health of farmers improves and their
income rose dramatically and
sometimes a gm approach is the only
option
in the 1990s the papaya industry in
hawaii was
under attack from the ring spot virus
which threatened to wipe out hawaiian
papaya
the solution was a papaya genetically
modified to be vaccinated against the
virus
without it the state's papaya industry
would have collapsed
all these stories show a very narrow
application
99 of all gmos we use right now
produce pesticides or are resistant
against them
there is so much more we could do
scientists are working on gmos that
could improve our diet
plants that produce more or different
nutrients
like fruit with higher antioxidant
levels that help to fight diseases
or rice with additional vitamins on a
larger scale
we're trying to engineer plants that are
more resilient to climate change
plants that can better adapt to erratic
weather and adverse soil conditions
making them resistant to droughts or
floods
gmos could also not only reduce
agriculture's impact on the environment
but actively help to protect it
scientists are working on crops that can
draw
nitrogen from the air like microbes
nitrogen is a common fertilizer
but its buildup pollutes the groundwater
and speeds up climate change
plants that collect their own nitrogen
could fix two problems at once
the overuse of fertilizers in the
developed world as well as the shortage
of it
in developing countries we could even
modify plants to become super effective
carbon collectors like the american
chestnut tree
to mitigate and actually reverse climate
change
with the tools we have today our
imagination is the limit
[Music]
the world eats 11 million pounds of food
every day
a un estimate suggests we'll need 70
more by 2050
we could grow that food by clearing more
and more forests to create fields and
pastures
and by using more pesticides or we find
a way to do it on the land we've got
right now
with more effective methods like gm
crops
intensifying farming instead of
expanding it means
gmos could become the new organic
in a nutshell gmos have the potential to
not only drastically change agriculture
but to also dampen the effects of our
own irresponsible behavior
gmos could be our most powerful weapon
to save our biosphere
this video took more than 600 hours to
make which would be impossible without
viewer support on patreon.com
if you'd like to support carefully
researched content made with love
it's really very helpful and you can get
your own bird as a reward
if you want to learn more about genetic
modification we have more videos
explaining the opportunities and risks
of the technology
and how it could impact our future